i want to tell you about a contest that i'm
running with a friend of mine james schloss
who some of you might recognize from the
youtube channel laos os and his twitch
stream and things like that also now there's a
3b1b podcast but more on that in just a moment
basically we want there to be more math
explanation online and we want to encourage
more people to get started actually doing it
we're calling it the summer of math exposition
where essentially we're just inviting anyone who
wants to to submit some kind of math explainer
whether that's a video or a blog post or an
interactive game or whatever it is that explains
math online in some way to the link that's
on screen now by august 22nd and then once we
yes i see you would you like to sniff at
the microphone oh yes that's very sweet
very sweet you're a very affectionate creature all
right where was i anyway after august 22nd we're
gonna have a selection process to choose some
winners from among them and then i'll feature them
in a three blue one brown video and then for the
rest i'll probably also put together a playlist
of all of the videos and a list of links on the
website somewhere to all the project submissions
and then i was also thinking maybe i
would send something to the winners like
creating some custom gold plushy
pie creatures or something like that
but the main prize is to have your work featured
and hopefully get it out to a few more people
the reason i'm interested in doing this is i
think there's a lot of people out there who
would be really good at doing this would
have some excellent explanation that would
genuinely help a lot of people or show a topic
that's not really covered very well elsewhere
and who might even be thinking about doing it you
know there's that back of your mind spot that says
maybe one day i'll try my hand at a video
or just write this up as a blog post
but you just never really got around to it you
know life's busy you're not sure where to start
it seems like there's a lot of other things out
there and my hope is that by dangling the tiniest
carrot that i can provide just mentioning good
work when it exists then maybe that gets a couple
more people over this hump who might otherwise
not have made something and then actually make it
so one of the very few constraints on entries
for this particular contest is that it has to be
something new it can't be a thing that you made a
while ago and you're just submitting a link to it
now but something that you make between now and
august 22nd and the real spirit of this all is
to encourage people who have never tried it before
to get started in it somehow the other constraint
is that it does have to be about math but math
in the broadest possible sense of the term so
that could include physics or computer science as
long as it's got some mathy components to it so
if you're doing physics and there's formulas that
are relevant don't shy away from those formulas or
if you're doing some computer science and there's
some you know algorithmic complexity or something
mathematical to it try to lean into that a little
bit more other than that the topic matter is
completely up to you so maybe you have some topics
that you've seen or that you've learned about but
which you really feel aren't covered well online
anywhere and it would really be adding something
new to the space maybe you're a physics buff who
is interested in the philosophical side of things
and you've learned about conway's freewheel
theorem and you want to talk about it and
whether that's an appropriate name whether it's
actually philosophically interesting or not
or just share with people what it is or maybe
you're someone who's into information theory
and things like that and you've learned about how
kolmogorov complexity can be used to describe some
things about the distributions of primes and you
think that's actually an interesting angle for how
to introduce kolmogorov complexity in the first
place or anything like this where it's something
kind of new to the space if that's you you should
definitely consider submitting but it doesn't have
to be a topic that no one has ever covered or
that's severely undercovered online even if it's
something that's very standard and especially
if it's something that a lot of students have
to reach at some point coming up with a better
way to explain it kind of thinking about what's
the state-of-the-art explanation on any particular
thing that could also add a lot to the space say
for example you've taught students about partial
fraction decomposition and tutoring or teaching
or something like that and you feel like you've
come across a way of explaining it that makes it
a little bit more memorable you should definitely
submit or maybe you have some really pretty way to
visualize certain trig identities that students
run into that keeps them from feeling very
rote and instead sheds a light on you know how
beautiful math can be and all that kind of thing
if that's you and you feel passionate
about it you should definitely submit that
one set of people who i'm particularly interested
in for this competition are the teachers and the
lecturers and basically anyone with a lot of
boots to the ground experience seeing people
learn and seeing what actually works because i
think there's a lot of outstanding explanations
out there that stay largely confined to
the classroom or otherwise stay offline
whereas if just a little bit of effort was put
into producing it or sharing it online in some way
those lessons might actually reach and benefit
one to two orders of magnitude more people
and i get it teachers are absurdly busy they
don't have time for extra things on the side
and it's kind of hard to know where to get started
so maybe one potential partnership here would be
the teachers who have really good
instincts for what works in education
and then a student who maybe has a lot of
energy or desire to get started on youtube or
otherwise just has more free time on their
hands and pairing something together like that
might actually make for a good partnership in
either case whatever category you fall into i
do know there's a lot of people who do want to get
started with this because they write to me a lot
and one of the most common sentiments out there
is well i don't know where to get started right
i want to make a video but i don't really have
any experience with video making things like that
and i have a couple things to say for
someone who feels like they're in that boat
in a kind of loose conjunction with this contest
i decided to start a podcast where for the first
many conversations i'll be interviewing people
who have some kind of experience in the space of
putting out explanations so that could be
other youtubers but it could also include
mathematicians who are really engaged with
outreach or the founder of khan academy things
like this and essentially have conversations
which act to either inspire or otherwise inform
anyone who might be getting started with
this after doing several of these interviews
one of the most useful pieces of information
that i think comes out from them is just how
ramshackle and unprofessional the setup for a lot
of people is in the very beginning and as a result
it should come as no surprise that one of the most
common pieces of advice one of the most universal
answers to the question of what advice would
you give to someone getting started with this
is to just start the things that differentiate
the people who actually put stuff out there
versus the ones who don't is not a matter of
having a lot more experience with it beforehand
it's a matter of having a kind of generative
spirit that just wants to make stuff
because my i'll say persona but this is g you know
me this is genuinely me is give it a go you're
probably going to fail but it's worth a try i get
a lot of people kind of saying oh you're like you
make youtube videos i've always wanted to make
youtube videos and i'm like great just do it and
they're like no no but i need to buy a nice camera
and i need to get a good set and i'm like no no no
like just do it there's always this temptation
wait am i ready yet am i ready yet and i just
say sal press record and start see what happens
if i take the example which i know best which is
my own there are so many really embarrassing
things about the early videos on this channel
or my process in creating them i mean the sound
quality was pretty terrible for a long time is
that's one big thing i edited in imovie for way
longer than i care to admit also despite being
now a like professional youtuber when it comes
to cameras and actually filming things like this
i really have no idea what i'm doing like right
now i'm just using a phone which i guess is fine
i find the process of being alone in a room
and just talking to a camera incredibly awkward
this is actually my second time recording this
whole video because the first time i thought i
would be really clever and have some notes to like
guide what i wanted to say and i'd put them on the
monitor next to the camera but what the result
was is that i would just kind of have my eyes
darting back and forth between the two without me
consciously realizing it it was just this reminder
that i really don't know what i'm doing but this
isn't a self-effacing thing the point here is that
if you find yourself with a potentially good
explainer that you want to make but you're a
little self-conscious about how to start or you're
worried that you're going to make a mistake just
don't worry about it just dive right in so many
of us have no idea what we're doing when we begin
all that said sometimes this just do it advice is
a little bit frustrating because i mean it's not
actionable you say okay i'm going to start but
then upon starting it tells you nothing so in
the spirit of some more concrete advice i do have
a couple things that i might want to pass along
that are specific to the case of math explainers
the first one and i do actually find this quite
important is when you're putting together the
explanation whatever form whatever medium whatever
genre you choose try to be aware of the layers
of abstraction that are relevant to your topic
so like if you're teaching a young child about
fractions and you're talking about two-thirds
plus one-fifth there's two different layers
of abstraction that that expression lives in
there's one where you have a very concrete example
of two-thirds of something two-thirds of a cake
and then one-fifth of a cake and trying to get
a sense of what that means and then there's the
symbols and a big part of the lesson at play here
is understanding how the symbols relate to the
actual case and why the rules that we apply to the
symbols make sense in light of the concrete case
and also why we opt to do the more abstract
thing because it takes much less thinking
than actually trying to reason about you know
two-thirds of a kick plus one-fifth of a cake
and this happens at all levels if you're teaching
a calculus class and you're talking about
optimizing functions you know there's the idea of
a function as a very abstract thing that could be
any particular function or any differentiable
function or what have you and then there's lots
of specific examples or maybe specific cases where
they come up like a function defining the profit
of a company and that's the thing you want to
optimize i made a whole video about group theory
where in the middle i went on for a while about
the difference between thinking of group actions
as these abstract entities versus as something
concrete like asymmetry and why there exists the
two and what the benefits and tradeoffs are but my
point in this first piece of advice is not merely
to address the layers of abtraction you don't
even have to but if you're clear in your own head
try very hard to structure your explanation to go
from the concrete to the abstract i think almost
always when you understand something the natural
inclination is to go the other way around i find
myself doing this in pretty much any first
draft of a script that i have it seems like
all the textbook authors that i ever read tend to
do this you start with the abstract idea you put
the examples later but i really do think that in
the case of learning first trying to populate the
learner's mind with a bunch of examples of things
that have a similar pattern between them and
letting their brain do the abstraction see that
similar pattern between things such that when you
bring in that higher layer you start defining you
know an abstract vector space or you're doing some
symbolic manipulations with particular rules that
once that happens you're articulating something in
the brain of the learner that was already sitting
there in the first place it wasn't just handed to
them in a vacuum otherwise it's a little bit like
trying to build a building from the top floor down
so that's one and that's very specific to math
as a more generic idea piece of advice number two
would be keep in the very forefront of your
mind the fact that content is king that the
thing that you're explaining the choice
of the topic or how you're explaining it
determines the majority of the value and the
quality of the thing that you make all the things
about production quality or you know how fancy the
animations are or the lighting or whatever it is
all of that is secondary to making sure you've
chosen an actually good topic and it's something
that people would want to consume they haven't
seen it elsewhere it's offering something fresh
now that's so easy to nod along with and say like
yes yes of course content is king but the thing
is you end up spending about one percent of your
time if that choosing what you're going to explain
and how you're going to explain it and then like
99 of the time just carrying it out in some way
and as a result it can be easy to lose sight of
that important part so my encouragement to you
would be spend more time than you would otherwise
tend to on choosing that topic so maybe workshop
a couple different things by doing sample lessons
with people or try to write out a list of all the
different things that you could and ask are they
actually fresh are they actually adding something
to the space is there a reason someone would want
to consume this spending that extra little bit of
time on the thing that determines the majority
of the value is almost certainly worth it
and the third piece of advice which maybe plays
into this a little bit is when you're beginning
if you're just starting something fresh and
there's no presence online at this point
try to choose something much more esoteric
and specific than you might be inclined to
i've seen a lot of people who want
to get started on youtube for example
and the way that they try to go about it is to
choose a topic that will appeal to the most people
after all they want their video to blow up they
want a lot of subscribers and things like that
but there's a couple issues with this first of all
it's a much more competitive space if you're going
to try to describe something that a lot of people
might be searching for so if you go in saying
i'm going to do a series about quantum mechanics
well there's a billion others out there and
yours is going to have to stand out for some
reason and you don't have a foothold at that point
but another one is that the very specific
and niche things build a much more loyal
audience in that beginning because you're offering
something which they could not find anywhere else
and sometimes to be the consumer of something very
specific is such a good feeling that you want to
pay it back and you find yourself rooting for the
creator so you're much more likely to get very
good faith feedback um just a warmer community
and also oftentimes we tend to overestimate
just how niche things are like sometimes
something that's so weirdly specific some very
esoteric bit of engineering actually appeals
to hundreds of thousands or millions of people
especially if you yourself are enthusiastic
about it and people can index on that so by doing
that you find yourself often with a topic that
actually does have a broader appeal but it's not
competitive with the things that everyone thinks
will have broader appeal and you potentially get
that audience loyalty when i started this channel
i really was thinking of it as a very niche thing
i did not think it would be a thing that a
lot of people would want to watch i actually
specifically wanted to find topics in math that no
one would think to search for that was kind of the
original conception that i wavered from a little
bit afterward the fourth piece of advice is to
pick a genre that your piece falls into so the
other day i was giving this talk to a group
of people and one of them wanted to get started
making online explainers and they asked whether it
was ethical for someone who's just barely learning
a topic just starting to learn it to also make
explainers of it online i mean after all they're
more likely to make mistakes they don't know the
broader context and there's so many things i like
about that question it's already demonstrating
a kind of care and consideration for factual
accuracy and doing right by the student that more
people who are making online explanations should
consider so like that very fact suggested to me
that this person probably should be doing it but
one of the things i suggested is to acknowledge
there are different types of explainers out there
there's the type where the narrator is a little
bit more distant they're kind of standing on top
of a hill and explaining the way that things are
and to do that you really have to research
the topic very deeply you should probably know
ten times as much about the topic as what
you're actually saying in the content
so that you know that you're teeing things up for
where it actually leads or you're being cognizant
of whatever nuances there are things like that but
another genre entirely is the discovery journalism
where the person who is learning the topic kind of
just admits that fact or is is open about the fact
that they're just starting with it and taking
the viewer along a journey with them and many
times that's actually a better piece of content
it's actually better for learning the topic
and it comes with this inbuilt piece of
humility that a lot of online content lacks
but there's lots of other genres like this there's
the worked example where you're explicitly helping
people with homework there's the try to find
an interesting demo and serve mainly to inspire
and basically just before you get started decide
which one of those you feel like you're the best
fit for and then when you're looking at other
pieces out there other explainers and trying to
index off of you know what seems to work what
doesn't be aware of which ones are in the lane
that you intend to be in and don't necessarily
pattern match off of the ones that aren't
you know one of the mistakes i think
i made with my very first video is
i had this conception that sometimes if you
talk faster than is comfortable on the internet
that sort of works that's like a satisfying thing
to consume because there are videos out there that
are this fire hose of information and something
about that scratches a niche and i think people
like it but what i didn't really appreciate was
the fact that math should fall into a completely
different category than that it is not fun at all
to have math come at you at this fire hose rate
and basically i was just pattern matching off
of things that i should not have been pattern
matching off of as point number five or i don't
actually know where i am at the list at this point
especially in the case of math if you're bringing
up definitions of things try not to let them feel
too arbitrary try to let them be well motivated
explain why that's the definition what else it
could have been try to make it something that
the learner feels like they discovered themselves
because too often we hand these things down on
high as the starting point and it's not really
clear why or where that came from so all of that
is just on the content side you know what exactly
are you explaining independent of the multimedia
component of it you know the sound and the video
and all that and like i said content is king that
definitely determines the majority of quality
but it does actually matter a little bit beyond
that to have at least a little bit of production
quality i think and i'll give a really good
example so i was watching this lecture the
other day by tadashi tokida on just a really
interesting set of ideas about applying physical
intuition to solving math problems and he had
in their maybe seven or eight outstanding little
arguments that each one of which could have
been just a beautiful video in its own right
but the you know the talk was over zoom and the
intro was really long and the sound quality is
everything that you assume from zoom and the
lighting of his shot was weird and the talk was
really good and i do think you know it's great
that it's online and a lot of people will be
consuming it but it's probably fair to say that
if all of that content the actual set of ideas
was instead say a number file video it would reach
100 times as many people and more than that it
would be a more pleasant experience for those who
are consuming it and it really doesn't take that
much so i'll just end with a couple pieces of
advice on that front the first one which again
i acknowledge is very hypocritical here is sound
quality actually matters especially in an era of
zoom where we are all inundated with this sort
of sub-optimal version of the voices of all the
people in our lives the learner will appreciate
a respite from all that with something that
actually comes from a good microphone
that you learned how to use at some point
on the side of visuals you know i'm obviously
a big believer in the idea that a well-chosen
illustration or an animation can really make
a mathematical idea a lot more clear and be an
example of that concretization and kind of going
from the lower layer of abstraction on upward by
just showing exactly what it is on screen in some
way now the way i do things is with programmatic
animations i sort of wrote this custom library
called manum to do that and last year actually a
group of people that called themselves the manum
community created a fork of it with the hope of
making a lot more user-friendly and i think
they succeeded with that there's a lot better
documentation it's better tested just all around
friendlier to use so you can use that tool and
thanks to them it's actually a lot easier than it
used to be there's some other libraries that i've
seen that mention manum as an inspiration you
know one that's written in julia or one that's
in haskell and it doesn't have to be programmatic
either i think where programmatic animations make
sense for math is if you're somehow leveraging
loops or conditionals or layers of abstraction and
in the right context i think it can be a wonderful
way to let the visuals authentically reflect
the math that you're describing if the code is
essentially just that math as it's illustrating
things but it doesn't have to be and a lot of
times people use manum or other programmatic
animations for things that do not need to be
programmatic that you could have easily done
in something like keynote or which add flashiness
for flashiness's sake that doesn't actually aid
with the explanation um i think one really good
example of using traditional animation software
is the channel borrbach so he really has these
friendly handwritten kind of whiteboard lectures
but uses animation to help those whiteboards come
alive and he uses adobe animate for that and i
think it's a really nice way to make this friendly
hand-drawn environment come to life which is
different from kind of the platonic stark this is
precisely what the math would draw when you're you
know illustrating a surface or something like
that also i see a lot of people use manum to
manipulate algebraic expressions and things like
that but if you look at other videos things like
mathologer you know he's doing a lot of that in
powerpoint and again content is king the first
thing is to focus on what are you actually
describing and then just showing it however
is easiest to show it in that case works totally
fine you don't need anything extremely precise
or that leverages loops and abstraction for the
formulas i recognize the kind of hypocrisy here
but you know i have walked myself into a certain
corner with the style that i want for the channel
if you do want to go down that hole of
programmatic animations though another tool
which has popped up recently is something called
smoothstep.io which i think is a really nice way
for people to get started with shaders which are
an absurdly powerful way to do absurdly beautiful
things and it's written by this guy matt henderson
who has a twitter account that everyone should
follow because he has some of the most beautiful
math illustrations that i think i've ever seen so
experimenting with software like that is another
rabbit hole that you could go down if say you
want to use this competition as an excuse to try
something new something that you've always wanted
to get started with but never really had the
excuse to do now if you have some pieces of advice
that you want to pass along to people or if you
want to just engage with the community in some way
to see what other people are thinking of making
or propose your own project ideas get feedback
talk about software anything like that we did set
up a discord space associated with the summer of
math exposition there's a link in the description
uh just be mindful if you do contribute to that
community that you want your comments to be
encouraging to others who are getting started
and productive to that goal and you know try to
avoid anything that is the opposite of that goal
and again another source of what will hopefully
include some inspirational or informative things
will be the podcast the first episode is out now
it's with the mathematician alex contorevich who
some of you may recognize from
the video he did with qanta or
the video he did with veritasium on pi day the
episode after that is going to be with sal khan
and there's just a really interesting lineup of
people here so i think you'll enjoy it you can get
it wherever you get your podcasts there's a video
version of it which is going to live on a second
channel that is just my name grant sanderson and
i figure for all future videos that are a little
bit like this one that's not really animated math
but other stuff that's probably the channel that
i'll put it on so keep an eye on that channel
if that's something that you're interested in
and i will say this about the podcast even
though the original intent was something that was
very much tied to this competition and the idea
of targeting people interested in getting started
a lot of the times i would find myself with
an interesting guest and i just have a whole
bunch of other things that i want to ask
them that have nothing to do with that
so maybe the better framing here is to say that
the podcast is 20 about that goal and the other 80
is just the usual interview style podcast
vibe where you have interesting guests and
i just want to ask things that i'm
genuinely curious to know about them
and then i get to grad school and i'm moving
into my my office in grad school and i have my
all my old papers and i just started you know for
fun leafing through them i don't know if you ever
look back at the stuff you wrote freshman
year and i look at him like what the hell
was i writing oh my god this is garbage this is
complete the epsilons and deltas are backwards
you can't have the epsilon deltas be backwards
and he only took off three points that would
have taken off you know nine or something
like romney was so nice so if lean was around
back then boy would it have straightened me out
it's actually very inspiring to me because i feel
one of the common pieces of advice that i'll give
to someone if they like want to learn more math
you